good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm
Maureen Johnson filling in for John
Green because once again he's
contributed to the birth of a human
child this is really nerve-racking for
me because I'm a writer like John but
like I don't make videos all the time
and you know I don't really think I'm
good at it so you know I got my camera I
got my water mom today's topic is the
Internet yeah the Internet the whole
thing some people don't like the
Internet and it can be for a number of
reasons for example there people like my
mom who gets confused by the Internet
and generally doesn't know how it works
and it's constantly afraid she's going
to break it Maureen Maureen Maureen the
people that hate or dismissed the
Internet often say things like well back
when I with the kid you know we didn't
consider out and watch porn all the time
make animated gif is oh yeah that may be
true but you probably also didn't engage
in a political discussion with a
thousand people so shut up I'm not
saying the level of discourse is always
high I mean I filled in for John when he
went on paternity leave the first time
and on my first video 90% of the
comments just said oh my god John has
boobs sometimes we are going to get
breaking news from the middle of a seat
of government and sometimes we're going
to have I just really love a cat and I
was under a bow the last two weeks have
been pretty fraud and there's been a lot
going on in the media in the world that
it's kind of hard to talk about it makes
us both want to talk all the time and
not know how to talk at all there's a
lot of split opinions there it's hard to
sort of know what to say to people who
are of a different viewpoint than you
without screaming ripping out your hair
just going nuts and turn into some kind
of crazy troll just thrown around the
internet going troll troll troll I just
want to watch the world burn and that is
not productive but it doesn't mean we
can't talk about this these things that
are difficult where our opinions differ
wildly in fact we have to talk about
these things and I think in many ways
the Internet is teaching us how to talk
to each other in a big way too big
way that we've never done before and we
are just learning the language of mass
discussion but it's easy to say we can
use the Internet to talk about things
but we all know it's actually really
difficult that's why you know the one
rule the internet is don't read the
comments but okay too late you've read
the comments it's already done what do
you do now
pause breathe look at some cats and ask
yourself what do you want to accomplish
do you want to further a good cause that
you're already part of or do you want to
punch a troll in the face and you
probably want to do both of those things
but you're probably only getting to be
able to accomplish one of them and that
probably shouldn't be too so focused on
one doesn't improve the situation of the
cause or whatever it is you're trying to
promote or encourage or talk about to
just punch a troll in the face and the
answer unfortunately is probably not it
doesn't make your side look good it
doesn't further the discussion
so therefore sadly a lot of times you're
not going to be able to make that
comment into a teachable moment what am
I even talking about just go for it
just answer all the trolls just do it
now troll patrol starts now let's do
this thing obviously start here start on
the start on this video start looking in
the comments now I mean I dub know your
moves no one knows how to internet if
anybody tells you they know it or not
just tell them to go eat some watermelon
cuz that's the only thing that makes
sense in this mixed-up world of ours I
don't know what you people want from me
just follow me on Twitter phenomenal I'm
dead swear I'm good player I'm not
hungry your videos very very good
Twitter though go there